They call it the roof of the world.
And it is one of the most isolated lens on the planet.
Surrounded by the world's highest mountains to bet has forever been a Lund of
monks on new months, a place seemingly frozen forever in tight.
I consider it.
It's kind of surprising that such a mysterious place can have such an impact on
international politics around the world.
Political activists hire the free Tibet flags and they wear t-shirts with the
logo embossed on the front. Meanwhile,
China is using all of its considerable political power to keep Tibet as part of
his territory. But why is this land so important? Does it have oil?
Does it have gold? No, it's got absolutely nothing. And this video,
we will tell you the story.
[Inaudible].
We should ask ourselves here is who on earth thought it was a good idea to
settle into bet. I mean, who's the first genius who said, Hey guys,
gather round. However,
we crossed the world's highest mountains while we freeze our asses off.
And then we start a human settlement on the other site.
And the middle of nowhere who's with me, starting a civilization was not enough.
We also managed to build more than 6,000 beautiful Buddhist temples and the most
unexplainable places you could possibly imagine. Yes. Brands of visual politics.
There are many inexplicable things about Tibet. In fact,
there are many things we don't know about a bit starting from the fact that the
name itself refers to three different things. First of all,
we have the Tibetan plateau, a massive area,
five times the size of France for an average elevation of 5,000 meters.
That's high enough to skydive from. So I'm told I've never been skydiving.
I'm scared of Heights. As you can see,
much of the plateau is shared with several other countries,
such as Bhutan and Pakistan,
and the area is home to other cultures and religions beyond just the Tibetans
and Buddhism. But as you know, Tibet is much more than an exotic place.
When talking about politics and Tibet, we usually refer to this Tibet.
This is known as the Tibet autonomous region or T a R as its name suggests as an
administrative area of China, but make no mistake is not actually autonomous.
The Chinese communist party rules. This region with an iron fist,
many Tibetans don't even have a passport. So they cannot travel abroad.
Their mother tongue has been completely bombed and most of those 6,000 beautiful
monasteries have been utterly demolished. Unfortunately,
none of this is really breaking news. I mean, what did you expect?
It's this China we're talking about.
They're not well-known for dealing with this end lately. In fact,
Tibetans are not the only minority group marginalized by Beijing. Then again,
Tibet as extremely important to their political agenda.
And the main reason is this man.
89 Dalai Lama wins the Nobel peace prize. New York times.
Lama is the religious leader of Tibetan Buddhism and the leader of the Tibetan
government in exile. He wants the tar to separate from China,
but I'm sure you already know this.
Everybody knows the Dalai Lama and why wouldn't he?
He's got such a cool haircut, which he called me from me. Just let it be known.
In 2013,
a pollster company called Harris conducted a survey with the most popular
leaders. The Dalai Lama came out in joint first place alongside Barack Obama.
This is surprising giving it to bet has just over 3 million people.
And it's almost impossible to reach.
You would be for Gavin for expecting to bet to be one of those unknown places
where human rights are violated all the time.
But you only heard about here on visual politics and one of our videos.
For example,
have you ever seen a demonstration in support of the rights of the younger
minority in China? Chances are,
you don't even know the people I'm talking about.
And yet the free Tibet campaign has gained the support of lots of influential
people, including Hollywood celebrities, like Richard Gere here in the city,
where I live in Prague in the Czech Republic,
you can see flags hanging out of windows that say three Tibet.
And if you think waving this flag has no political consequences.
You had better think again. Remember, this is China. We're talking about.
Bangladesh show covers up to bet Nard after China complainants
train his revenge for Prague's supports of Tibet,
trying to complains to us over lawmakers, visit the Dalai Lama.
The thing about all of this as is that China has plenty of other international
problems to deal with. Do you want territorial conflicts?
You've got the dispute with Japan on the East China sea and ongoing border
clashes with India to the South. Want to hear about oppressed of minorities?
You can read about the year, my naughty every day in the newspapers. Yes,
dear viewers Tibet is not China's only problem,
but China takes a bet very seriously.
Even talking about it with N Jayna is prohibited,
which by the way is also a rule that applies to talking about my teeth and the
comments I'm British. What did you all expect outside of China?
Naming this specific problem as a synonym for having a diplomatic?
Okay. You might wonder.
Why is it because of economics? I mean,
not really debate is chain poorest region. Is it because of oil? Not really.
So what then? Why is China so invested in keeping Tibet in the territory?
Why is this such a huge deal in international politics?
It's China really entitled to claim Tibet as a region and this video,
we are going to answer all of these questions, but before we do,
let's take a look back at something.
Last corner of the earth.
Does the name [inaudible] ring a bell for you?
This is the name of the Dalai Lama. In fact,
seeing Dalai Lama is like saying the Pope,
just like the Pope is the head of the Catholic Christianity.
The Dalai Lama is the head of Tibet and Buddhism.
And just like the Pope is the leader of the Vatican States.
The Dalai Lama is the political leader of the Tibetan government in exile.
It's a fun fact for you. Well,
how well do you think Tenzin was when he was named Dalai Lama?
The answer is he was five years old. Yes, dear viewers,
the Dalai Lama is not elected democratically and he's not even choosing by luck
of inheritance.
The Dalai Lama is the reincarnation of a goddess who has such a complicated
name. I'm not even going to try to pronounce it because let's face facts.
I can barely speak English as it is. So once the title I Lama passes away,
the religious authorities start looking for the next human and to whom the Dalai
Lama has been reincarnated, which by the way,
is how we choose new hosts here on visual politic.
And how do they recognize that? I don't know, ask it to bet in Buddhist.
I just looked like one, but once they find the true Lama,
they crone him as the King of Tibet.
And then he will rule the country as the absolute Monarch until he passes away.
Okay.
Political system Tibet has had since 1391 in the meantime,
Tibet has been conquered by the Mongolians and the Chinese,
but it kept that feudal and theocratic system almost untouched.
They just paid tribute to the Chinese dynasties that controlled them basically
for centuries. Nobody really cared.
Tibet.
So isolated and hard to reach the Buddhism or religion famously associated with
Tibet. Didn't actually reach the Tibetans until the seventh century a D.
This is over a thousand years after Buddhism was funded.
Tibet developed a feudal system where local chiefs shared power with monks and
monasteries.
That's explains why until recently they had more than 600,000 monks and nuns and
a population of as few as 2.5 million inhabitants modern technology didn't
arrive until very recently, but all of this changed and the 20th century,
first between 1912 and 1950,
the Chinese dynasties completely withdrew from Tibet.
It seemed that this country could be completely sovereign forever and even more
isolated. But as you know, destiny had other plans for Tibetans.
This war without bloodshed, while war is politics with bloodshed mouths,
they don't.
October 6th, 1950, the Chinese people's liberation army crossed,
entered Tibet and inflicted a crushing defeat on the Tibetan army.
There was no need for a genius strategy here.
China had about 550 million inhabitants. Well, Tibet had less than 2.5 million.
Also.
It's a better than government having taken an extreme isolation as policy had no
international allies to aid them.
So despite Tibet being an easily defensible location,
it was really terribly easy to conquer them out of the time,
the 14th Dalai Lama, the same one we have today was only about 16.
And he sent a delegation to Beijing to negotiate. A deal has approval.
This delegation,
which also wasn't allowed to communicate back to the Tibetan government,
signed the 17 point agreement. This agreement resulted in China,
annexing to banks, but it left the area with some actual autonomy,
similar to the situation in Hong Kong today,
the Dalai Lama could remain in power and the traditional Tibetan system known as
the cache. It could remain in place. And so I know what you're thinking so far,
nothing's really changed, right?
For centuries to best leaders had a free reign to rule their country as long as
they would pay tribute to whoever ruled China first,
it was the aristocratic dynasties. And now it's the communists.
What's the difference? The difference is, and the details.
Of course.
To the Chinese communist party,
only part of Tibet to could have that degree of autonomy,
but the East of the country would fall under most reforms.
So the people living in those areas rebelled against communist rule using
guerrilla warfare tactics.
This was made worse when the rebellion began to spread through the rest of
Tibet. So in 1959, males are dong said, you know what the hell with autonomy,
let's give these Tibetans some real liberation on March 17th,
Chinese artillery shells struck near the Dalai Lama's palace,
which prompted attempt to flee to India disguised under cover of darkness.
Of course, this anger,
Tibetans who loved the religious leader and they began large scale protests,
which eventually turned to violence.
As you can probably imagine the Chinese communist army responded in a very
Chinese communist way, total brutal repression.
And what do you think happened next? I mean, think about it.
We are talking about the end of the 1950s in the middle of the cold war.
On one hand, we have a communist country invading a non-communist country.
This was a golden window of opportunity for.
[Inaudible] CIA gave aid to Tibetan exiles and sixties files
show.
Oh, no one ever expects the CIA. So yes,
the U S armed the Tibet and rebels and subsidize the Dalai Lama while he was
living in exile.
The CIA spent more than 1.7 million us dollars a year supporting the free Tibet
by a hundred thousand us dollars went to Armenia gorillas and 180,000 us dollars
went to the Dalai Lama. This is how this regional conflict turned international.
All of a sudden the whole world knew about the Dalai Lama and free Tibet became
one of the most popular human rights campaigns worldwide.
While in exile in India,
the Dalai Lama created a Tibetan library and made Tibetan Buddhism known in
unexpected places like the us and Europe.
I'm sure many of you have a Tibetan Mandela home,
or you have a friend who has Lotus flowers in their bedroom.
If you do a Google search,
you will find lots of websites and newspapers supporting the Tibetan codes and
Hollywood celebrities have been extremely vocal on this topic. Just check.
Saving Tibet. You save the possibility that we are all brothers, sisters,
Richard Gere,
Steven Seagal, top action hero, and to Betten llama.
By the way, as a fun fact, all of this American AIDS stopped in 1972.
The very same year that the white house started diplomatic relations with
continental China. So now you may wonder there was all this free Tibet movement,
just a CIA conspiracy.
Was it just a way to destabilize communist China during the cold war?
Have we been manipulated all this tight? The fact that the CIA was involved,
it does not mean China didn't act inappropriately towards Tibetans.
So let's keep going. The last set of Tibet and uprising ended in 1962,
by then it's estimated that the Chinese army had looted and destroyed over 6,000
Tibetan monasteries and killed perhaps as many as 87,000 Tibetans,
But that wasn't the end of it.
In 1966 Mao's cultural revolution began 15 years later, there were only eight.
Yes, eight functioning monasteries left in Tibet,
where there had previously been thousands and 1950 as believed.
There were as many as 600,000 Tibetan monks and nuns. And by 1979,
they were almost all debt. The damage is almost impossible to understate,
but this raises the question. Why,
why are the Chinese so determined to keep ahold of Tibet? Let's have a look,
shall we.
[Inaudible] access of Asia?
Why does China want to bet even today to bet ranks lowest on the human
development index?
I have all of China's 31 provinces and a significant portion of the population
holds a real resentment toward the ruling communist party to boot well and true
visual politic fashion. The answer is both complicated and simple.
Let's have a look at a up again and get ready for some terrible pronunciation.
[Inaudible].
See all this.
These are the many rivers fed by the ice melt from the Tibetan plateau.
These rivers include the youngest and the yellow,
the two most important rivers in China. Also the Metcon,
which allows Cambodia and Vietnam relay on everybody that sustains Myenmar the
butter and Holy Ganges of Bangladesh and India. The end is the defiance,
Pakistan,
and many other smaller ones that nourish places like the Oasis of the Taran
basin. So you see why it's so important now, whoever controls, Tibet controls,
almost all of Asia's fresh water and the water that about half of the world's
population relies on. And as you can imagine,
China knows how to use such a strategic resource.
[Inaudible].
And it completes Tibet speakers, hydro power plants.
China now has around 87,000 water dumps. Two thirds of those are built into bed,
and that's not all in 2007, the Chinese government found large mineral deposits.
And we've seen that Tibet is home to large amounts of gold copper lead and zinc
so much. In fact,
that it may account for about half of all of China's copper and zinc. Of course,
there are several environmental concerns linked to all this.
And India is worried about the Chinese control of Asian waters.
At the end of the day.
Many of those rivers that stream from Tibet are the lifeblood.
[Inaudible].
No,
you might be thinking you might be thinking it doesn't sound so bad after all
grants being invaded by China is not great,
but why if that invasion brings money and jobs to the people that's not so bad.
Let's be honest though, here prior to the Chinese invasion,
Tibet was far from a good place to live.
And if you look at the pure statistics to best GDP has been growing a constant
two digit rate for more than 25 years.
That's a lot of money and jobs were the problem with that. Then, well,
most of that money and most of those jobs go straight to the ethnic.
Chinese who have migrated to TV.
[Inaudible].
Steer viewers, race matters a lot in China.
90% of the best population are ethnically Tibetan.
Only 8% belong to the hand minority,
which is the majority race throughout the rest of China.
Most of those ethnic Chinese immigrated to the region after the envision.
And those are the ones who get to work and all of those better paying jobs,
the rest of the Tibetans remain pure.
So basically if you belong to the Tibetans majority.
This is what you get from all of them.
[inaudible].
Nomads, forcibly resettled by China,
struggle with loss of an over 8,000 year old heritage.
First post 29.
[Inaudible].
Ends in anguish as Chinese minds pollutes their sacred grass.
It's a large lithium mine, not only desecrates,
the sacred grasslands villagers say, but spawns, deadly pollution.
The river used to be full of fish today. There are hardly any hundreds of yaks.
The villagers say have died in the past few years after drinking Riverwalk,
the Washington post 2016.
So according to a census conducted by Beijing university,
only 1% of Tibetans have immigrated to the rest of China by 2010.
And the few who made it usually had a hard time finding a good job in cities
like Shanghai or Beijing. Basically that means if you are to Tibetans,
you have few opportunities at home and even fewer in China,
all of this explains why despite China's efforts to suppress the bet and culture
many still follow the Dalai Lama. On the other hand,
the current Dalai Lama is very different from his predecessors.
He has spent most of his life outside of Tibet.
He's been among Western leaders and this has influenced his political views.
[Inaudible].
Dalai Lama, proclaimed success of Tibetan democracy,
handover government duties to elected, to Betten leader.
All of this means that if one day the Dalai Lama comes back to Tibet,
he won't be the absolute theocratic Monarch. He was decades ago.
This time he would support a democratic government with a parliament and an
elected leader. But so far,
it seems very unlikely that China will let Tibetan separatists have their way.
So no, the question is over to all of you. Well,
it's the battens retain their culture and way of life. Well,
the Dalai Lama ever returned will they achieve independence or even just real
autonomy. Will there ever be a free Tibet?
We'd love to hear your opinions and the comments down below. Also,
don't forget to visit our friends from reconsider media.com.
The podcast provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones.
Don't forget that we publish brand new videos every week. So some scrape.
And if you had the little button down there, you will get updates.
Whenever we put out a new video, if you liked this video,
give us a thumbs up it's free. And that is a great price. Once again,
I'm Scottish and copper wire was invented when two Scotsman's were fighting over
a penny,
and she's also been noted that YouTube is taking an increasingly anti creator
stance in favor of legacy, media and corporations.
And we're basically one edge video away from being totally demonetized.
So if you want to keep us going as your favorite independent source of political
news, check out our Patrion in the description down below,
and as always see you guys next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice,
come check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you.
Find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.